ん
今日は皆様
ほとんどの皆様は
政府映画をご覧になっていると思いますスタートレックスよスター申すのような映画を
ご覧張っていると思います
でも今お見せしているのは英政府の映画でもありませんコンピューターグラフィックス
でもありません
これは方もののビデオで私だと私の乗員仲間がスペースシャトルディスカバリー
に乗船しているとき
撮った映像ですこれは2010年のことで iss 国際宇宙ステーションから
切り離された時からとっている映像です
iss は未だに
地球の周りを麻波25音速25デー
集亜洲会をしていますこれは秒速8キロんの速度ですで今お見せしているのも実際の
速度であり早送りをしていません
今日は皆様と3つのことをご共有したいと思っております
まずは地球の美しさんです
このビデオでご覧いただけもストーリー素晴らしい自然を見ることができます山川白い
雲そして青い海そして時には
北極南極では素晴らしいオーロラなども見ることができます
本当に息を飲むばかりですでも同時に音がおくべきことなんですけれども
地球を取り木大気層があまりにも薄いということです
そしてわたしたちは皆この薄い
脆弱なそう大気層によって守られているということを知ると驚きます
そして太陽が昇りそして落ちるまで
これは90分に1回起こるんですけれども
大待機層の薄い層が虹のように光りますとても美しいです
そしてバックミンスターフラー氏はかつて宇宙のことを宇宙船主事95と述べました
私自信は本当に地球は宇宙船だと感じました
よろしくです
でもちろん大きいのですけれども無限でもない土地も資源も有限であるという意味で
宇宙船と感じました
ということで宇宙船地球号を
より良い方法で使っていかなければなりませんというのも世界人口もまたエネルギー
消費量もどんどん増えているからですですので宇宙船地球号を自分たちの持てる
資源を対立を助けるのではなく積極的に使えるようにうまく使いこなしていかなければ
なりません
二つ目に共有したいアイディアとしては人間の力の話です
に choo 目
素晴らしい自然が目の前に展開しますでも夜にバンパーです
都市の照明が
輝いてー
美しいのですね
マイファスせ陰謀
これは人間の文明の象徴かのようです
また
iss を向いてびっくりしたことがあるのです
iss に対して近づいてってそしてビデオで見ているように iss から離れて
いる時に驚いたんですけれども幅は100メートル長さ75メートルの iss は
ちょうどサッカー場と同じくらい巨大なものなのですけれども
これは洲国際的な協力あって
以外できないことですということで人間の呼吸を超えた協力の賜 siss
プロジェクトは1980年代に西洋諸国が始めたプロジェクトです
ヨーロッパーアメリカカナダ日本が主要国でさそして冷戦が
終わった後
これは1990年初頭ですけれども
冷戦が終わってからはロシアが参加を始めました
ということで事態はどんどん変わっていきます
様々な多くの国々が協力をきっとするんだと思います将来の有人宇宙探査船に関して
です
例えば月やそれより遠いところに宇宙船五反さあを送ることに関してです
というのがこういった火星に探査船を送るようなプロジェクトというのは異国ではやり
きれません
ということでより大規模な国際協力が必要です
そのためにもグローバル経済
グローバル政治はより安定していなければなりません
私たちはボーダーレスな国境を越えた協力が必要です
で公共がないというところで私たちは
たぶんこの宇宙探査船のの中でも協力をより小境を越えてしたダイス大行くともっと
より良いことが起きていくと思います
こういうより良い品地効果がますます地上とそして宇宙の間で進むことを願っています
最近私は感銘を受けたことがあります
冥王星の写真を見たからです
ニューホライズンズ探査機が撮った映像ですけれどもこの達成に対しておめでとうと
申し上げたいと思います
って世界中の
人々がこのスペースミッションに対して貢献をしてくださりそしてサポートして来て
下さったことに対しても感謝を申し上げます
最後にもう一点共有したい点があります母なる宇宙マザースペースです
初めて宇宙に到達をしてそして無重力を
経験したときこれはちょうどあの
discovery が打ち上げられて8分30秒後のことだったんですけれども本当
にびっくりしました
無重力に入ると宙返りは何回も出来るのですそして天井からは自由に風呂が下がります
そしてまた天井に立つことも問題なくできます
絶対的な上4
だというのはないのです皆さんの耐性に応じて上と下が決まってきます
ということで
あなたの場合の上のほうを向いて歩いはあなたの場合の下を向いてというふうに人に
よって体制が違うので言わなければなりませんでした
本当に目からウロコが落ちるような経験でした
他の人の立場に立たない限り自分たちはコミュニケーションができなかったのです
んそして感銘を受けたのは
なぜか初めて宇宙に着いた時に馴染みのあるところだと感じたことです初めてなのに
身近な場所と感じたのです
私たちは皆星のカケラからできています
太陽地球そしてどの生物私たちも含めて皆星のカケラから構成されています
つまり
宇宙は私たちにとって遠い存在ではありません
多分私たちの故郷なのですだからこそ
多分身近に家を感じたんだと思います
だから私は宇宙をマザースペースと呼びたいと感じています
mother スペースは
私たちのために私たちの幸せと平和んを祈ってくれているはずです
ちょうど親が子の幸せを祈るかのようにですあるいは教師が子どもの幸せを願うように
ですそして母なる宇宙マザースペースは私たちが成長してさ
のに成熟している姿を見たいはずですそしてマザースペースは私たちが互いに気を使い
あってそして前向きに体を携えて地上でも頑張るところを見て
いたいと思うはずです
宇宙は本当に美しくでも地上にまた戻ってきた時風を感じました
そして警官を見ましたそして小さな花々草花の匂いを変えた時に本当に嬉しく幸福感が
ありました
ということで本当の幸福感が私たちの周囲にあるんだと思います
遠いところにあるわけではありません
そういったことを考えると
より国々は小境を越えて
コネクトしていくつながっていくと思いますそして地上と宇宙も繋がっていくに違い
ありません
そしてマザースペースは私たちがもっと協力をすることを待っていると思っています
協力をして私たちがもっとさらに頻度を多く宇宙に行ける
そして
彼女に会いに行くこと望んでいるんだと思いますですので私はさらに多くの人々が宇宙
に行けるように尽力をしたいと思います
そしてそれはあの国境のない政界により貢献をしていくと思います
母なる宇宙マザースペースはわたしたちを待っていてくださると思います
ご静聴ありがとうございますそして皆さんテッドの主催者の皆様ご尽力をありがとう
ございます